all right welcome everybody I'm being
told on Twitch that there's a celebrity
that has a crush on me that's very very
that may be the most interesting uh
breaking news related to the David
packman show
I would argue in history to be to be
perfectly Frank uh but we'll we'll get
to that a little bit later
um because we are here with
um finally for I guess finally for those
of us who are waiting and I don't know
that everybody was waiting we are going
to be seeing a public appearance from
president Donald Trump for the first
time since the riotous Insurrection that
he incited
um although we did hear from him just a
few statements as he was heading out of
the White House and I'm going to play
that video
for you momentarily but we're standing
by for Donald Trump in Texas for
statements about the border wall now I I
don't want to sort of give up the the
the speech ahead of time but my guess is
Trump will claim that he kept his
promise on the wall and that Mexico paid
for it neither of those things are true
Trump's promise was a wall across the
entire border now thankfully he failed
to do that but he did fail
um and Mexico didn't pay for anything we
paid for it as taxpayers okay so that is
uh that that's that's the reality
um okay what do we have there's just so
much I don't even know where to start
because there's so much going on we are
sort of building towards
the end of this Administration
which will
um be happening at noon in eight days a
week from tomorrow and we will be
covering the Biden Inauguration live I
don't have any any particularly special
plans for the Biden inauguration other
than just to cover it and on now
unfortunately I hope this isn't the case
but there's a good chance we will be
covering violence as well
and I think you all know that by you
know the FBI has put out a statement
saying they're expecting violent mobs in
all 50 states and DC
so it I I it's not like I'm encouraging
anybody that this they've been talking
about this on parlor and Elsewhere for a
while I'm very worried that we are going
to see significant violence on but as
soon as this weekend really and leading
all the way up to inauguration day
okay
um a few super chats coming in that are
interesting what's your take on the idea
of instead of impeachment implementing
the 14th Amendment to Bar Trump for from
public office well they can do that as
part of impeachment with a simple
majority vote okay uh chakasecki says
Trump administration's human sedition
ped has now morphed into a human pardon
ped as they slowly crawl while attached
at the face to his rump wow also trumpty
Dumpty sat on his wall trumpty Dumpty
had a great fall into ignominious defeat
sedition treason legal catastrophe and
erection fraud wow that's very
aggressive that's extremely aggressive
but I um I appreciate it okay let's get
to Trump's statements as he was so we
have statements he made heading out to
Texas and then upon Landing let's just
take it from the top uh we are standing
by for Trump at the border wall but here
was what Trump said on his way down
[Music]
so we're going to Texas we're going to
the southern border as you know we've
completed the wall they may want to
expand it okay so they've not completed
the wall now when Trump says they've
we've completed it but they may want
might want to expand it
the promise was a wall across the whole
border if that's complete how do you
expand it into the water
no I don't know it's weird it's the
expansion underway
beyond what anyone thought we were
stopping in large numbers the drugs
coming into the country for many many
years and decades were stopping a lot of
illegal immigration our numbers have
been very good there does seem to be a
surge now because people are coming up
some Caravans and starting to form again
the Caravans are starting again my
friends because they think there's going
to be a lot in it for them if they're
able to get through but we're able to
stop it the wall has made a tremendous
difference I think some of you are
coming with me but the wall has made a
tremendous difference on the southern
border as far as this is concerned we
want no violence never violence well too
late for that you may have you know you
didn't cite that Riot we want absolutely
no violence and on the impeachment it's
really a continuation of the greatest
Witch Hunt in the history of politics
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous this impeachment is causing
tremendous anger right ignore why there
is is even a discussion of impeachment
ignore that just the fact that there
might be an impeachment is causing anger
what's what's a good I I want you guys
to help me Workshop some analogies for
Trump now saying no violence is like so
here's here's the gist of the analogy I
want you to help me Workshop it
the arsonist who says after the house
burned down I'm getting rid of all of my
matches that's the type of analogy what
ideas do people have that I may be able
to integrate closing the Barn Door after
the cows left that's not bad
that's not bad
um
what what other ideas do we have as to
far of the as far as the analogy to that
Cookie Monster saying no to cookies no
that doesn't make any sense
aborting a two-month-old baby okay
that's that's a little that's that's not
going taking the bullets out of a gun
after you shot someone turning the gun
in after you've already used it to kill
someone that's not bad that's not bad
I saw online uh putting your seat belt
on after you've already arrived at the
destination
um
all right well I'm not seeing too many
excellent ones but let's keep
workshopping it let's continue
and you're doing it and it's really a
terrible thing that they're doing
four
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer to
continue on this path I think it's
causing tremendous danger to our country
you know the I could have sworn that the
dangerous thing was not a
constitutionally mandated procedure to
hold the president accountable I thought
the dangerous thing was the violent
Insurrection that's where I see the
danger and it's causing tremendous anger
I want no violence thank you very much
thank you everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so then upon Landing we heard from
him again
this audio is atrocious
anybody hear that I can't hear a word of
what he's saying
there we go dividing and divisive and
they're showing something that I've been
predicting for a long time oh he's
talking about big Tech
I've been predicting it for a long time
and people didn't act on it but I think
big Tech has made a terrible mistake and
very very bad for our country and that's
leading others to do the same thing and
it causes a lot of problems and a lot of
danger a big mistake they shouldn't be
doing it but uh there's always a counter
move when they do that I've never seen
that's another that's another illusion
to some I mean listen I'm not saying
that that's an allusion to violence but
again it's another illusion to signaling
his his crowd to do something it's anger
as I see right now and that's a terrible
thing terrible thing and you have to
ways very anti-free Market very very
anti-free Market avoid violence and we
have we have tremendous support we have
support probably like nobody's ever seen
before he's still using that line always
avoid violence and that was a glitch did
you guys notice that he had that glitch
there we've seen those we've seen those
before where he kind of glitches on a
particular word and shakes up we have
support probably like nobody's ever seen
before always have to avoid violence
there it is
so if you read my speech and many people
have done it and I've seen it both
perfect speech in the
on television it's been analyzed and
people thought that what I said was
totally appropriate and if you look at
what
people have said politicians at a high
level about the riots during the summer
the horrible riots in Portland Seattle
and various other other places
that was a real problem right yeah the
right the breaking into the capital it
had nothing to do with him and it wasn't
a problem and it was antifa the stuff in
Seattle though that's really really
crazy stuff so there's Trump's statement
upon Landing in Texas and we're standing
by for him right now uh we are expecting
to hear from him
any moment in about 15 minutes all right
so glad uh glad that you were with us
let me say thank you to the six folks
who just grabbed twitch subscriptions I
really do appreciate that that you're
doing that and I also want to say thanks
to a few people who grabbed
subscriptions on my website Daniel Dorn
just signed up at joinpakman.com and
Aaron Isaacson as well new members
number seven and eight today
very much appreciate that
um albix Rurouni says it's like trying
to put sunglasses on after you've stared
at the solar eclipse exactly I like that
I like that very very much
uh okay so we've gotten that out of the
way
um a couple of other things that I
wanted to go over oh oh I I have two new
voicemails so when Democrats took
Georgia and Republicans tried to take
the Capitol building the Via violent
insurrection
I stopped hearing from all of our
regular trumpist callers I didn't hear
from repeater I didn't hear from
prickless guy I didn't hear from Troy
York under his real or fake names Troy
York now is very much back he called in
under his fake name Ramon Ramos which is
his fake Hispanic character and he also
called in with a new character named
Dimitri diamond
I don't know if Dimitri diamond is
supposed to be a Russian Dimitri I don't
know do you guys want to hear the
Dimitri Diamond Troy York call first or
the Ramon Ramos and by the way I know
that that's not in Spanish the last name
is Ramos right I understand that but
it's Ramon Ramos is how he pronounces it
um
Dimitri Diamond first okay let's take
this is this is Troy York as Dimitri
diamond
here we go
hey hello David this is Dimitri Diamond
uh just calling I really enjoy your show
I think you got one the best uh internet
uh alternative oh so Dimitri diamond is
a character that likes the show news
programs out there right I highly
recommend it to many people uh however I
think that um
um you should have more of an open mind
about the possibility of election fraud
and this um well I did I had an open
mind to the evidence and the evidence
took me to it doesn't exist not be too
surprising especially given
um that most countries that have
elections
uh are fraudulently tampered with and
interfered and not very honest
um they're not honest I believe that um
basically you have a ruling Elite around
the world who controls elections and if
they don't want somebody they will uh
guarantee that the person loses set up a
coup is uh kind of like in Egypt where
Muhammad or see how he was elected yet
in the U.S and your EU sponsored a coup
okay so anyway that's that that's
Dimitri Diamond here is Ramon Ramos this
is all the same guy this was like a
couple hours later
um
but wow five in the morning so that
first call I played for you was one in
the morning so this guy it seems like
this guy's up all night because he left
he left the Dimitri Diamond voicemail at
1am
and then this one now is 5 am
D this is renowned Ramos uh
about the
uh you had phone callers he's from not
even American he he from Australia and
he wondered why he why Australian called
you you programming so concerned with
American politics but I digress uh let
me ask you this is Washington DC becomes
a state
um uh Waianae Oklahoma City uh and so it
could be a red State what sense does
that make I think uh this is complete
nonsense in Washington DC you talk about
uh you want to become a Saints for two
more sentences for Democrat Party well
the the make Tulsa then Tulsa can become
States a similar population
uh Tulsa already has representation but
this is a very very silly argument it
makes no sense you stupid Washington DC
I'm stupid she can be Honestly made uh
incorporate to Baltimore to Maryland and
Maryland the already Democratic State
well Maryland's already Democrat if
Maryland's already a stage no reason for
a 51st state uh Puerto Rico much like
Cuba most Puerto Ricans which I am uh
actually more traditional the the ones
in Puerto Rico uh the liberal Puerto
Ricans mostly migrate to U.S other Latin
American countries they they want their
Urban
[Music]
hedonistic lifestyle thing they're
already in America they already vote
this you have Puerto Rico as a state
there's no guarantee they'd be Democrat
unless they regular election okay so you
stupid you you know nothing about the uh
Puerto Rico not guaranteed to be
Democrat it's weird because I actually
said during the call he's referring to
where people were asking about DC and
Puerto Rico I said Puerto Rico has a
larger conservative element than many
people might imagine and it's not a
guarantee that if you make Puerto Rico a
state that it's completely Democratic in
its representation
Los Angeles
you you very stupid Argentine you're not
using Puerto Rican you well yeah I never
I never claimed to be Puerto Rican I'm
Argentinian that's true you're not even
Hispanic you well that's a different
question
oh and it just glitched
all right anyway that's I guess as far
as we're gonna be able to go with that
because it just the entire voicemail
system just glitched okay so I mean I
guess it was it it's true that I am not
Puerto Rican that I think we can say
with certitude was an accurate
um
that was an accurate comment for sure
a kinky Turtle says isn't making fun of
this guy ableism oh boy I we can't even
delve into that right now Jennifer says
three o'clock press conference with FBI
doj about the capital attack okay that I
am very interested in
do you know if any YouTube channel is
covering it I'm glad to go to that after
the Trump thing because the Trump thing
may not be very long let me see um FBI
Capital attack press conference
um yeah I'm not seeing any live stream
right now
but I would be I would be interested in
covering that
if anybody can tell me who's streaming
it live but we'll get back to that okay
I have a couple just a couple of other
Clips to play for you I do want to say
thanks to the nine additional twitch
subscribers who just did sign up via
twitch and also a big thank you to Peter
Brennan who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
18 today
um warning
coupon code is now better 21 the
discount is so big I don't even publish
it we just say massive discount that's
on advice of council we hired celebrity
lawyer Mark garagos and he said these
discounts are so explosive I wouldn't
even publish the amount just say it's a
big discount
um and that's that's that's where we're
going right now PBS NewsHour is covering
it okay let's see PBS NewsHour live
um house to debate house rules committee
man I'm not finding this the exact right
stream is the only issue house rules
committee
oh oh here it is perfect perfect perfect
okay good so after Trump speaks and we
expect Trump's statement to be very
short we will go to this
um update on the capital attack now they
should really spell it capital with an O
but that's okay I know that A lot's
going on right now so we'll stand by for
that
um I think that that'll be very very
important I read that a second
impeachment would strip 45 of Secret
Service detail and other Financial
benefits not not by default you so you
need 60 votes to in the Senate to
convict on impeachment but with a simple
majority with a simple majority you can
strip Trump of his million a year
um uh travel budget and
um prevent him from being able to run
again that's absolutely true yep uh okay
a couple of other things I wanted to
mention
do I think we'll see more one-term
presidents in the near future maybe you
know it's it's hard to say at this point
in time
um they can't imagine someone could want
democracy for democracy's sake and not
simply to benefit their political party
yeah it's sad
are we sure Ramon Ramos is not really
Alec Baldwin's wife faking a male Latino
accent yeah you know I didn't really
follow that story very much about uh
Hilaria ilaria Baldwin
um but I heard on the Howard Stern Show
yesterday that I guess
she's she's admitted to faking a Spanish
accent you know at one point I thought
that Alec Baldwin's wife was Argentinian
and then I found out she's like from
Boston or something
um and then I realized no Matt Damon's
wife is Argentinian
I believe Bobby Duvall's wife is
Argentinian and
hold on who else is who else is uh what
other actors wives are Argentinian
there's a few
yeah I know that the Wolf of Wall Street
who I know is dating an Argentinian
woman that I know
um Baldwin yeah Matt Damon yeah Maradona
obviously that's not an American actor
though
yeah anyway okay yeah I've so that was a
mistake on my end that was a mistake I
just that was a mistake have I talked
about the gender rules the house plans
to adopt they seem bizarre to me no I
I've not heard of that that's not
something I've heard of
BMA Stellar via twitch sub says couldn't
Trump be charged for 14th Amendment
violations after January 20th as I
believe that that's the case yes Anya
Taylor Joy from uh Queen's Gambit is
Argentinian that's absolutely true
braylon's dad says irony if the GOP had
won the popular vote that would be their
entire argument right now of course it
would
of course it would
Rocco Thompson says didn't think I could
love you more and now I discover you're
a Stern fan the perfect man does exist
yeah I've been listening to Howard Stern
for let's see I think I think 22 years
or something like that and I admit the
last few months I've been listening very
little because it's been
um it's just been so busy with
everything that's uh that's that's been
going on
uh okay
you need a 67 vote majority to convict
in the Senate I I apologize uh that was
it yes you need a 67 vote majority for
impeachment in the Senate you only need
a simple majority a simple majority to
strip Trump of the ability to run again
in the future that's my mistake I
apologize for that big thank you to the
14 additional twitch subscribers who
just signed up putting us at 32. I see
people asking what's the most twitch
Subs we've ever had it's right around
2500 and it was last month
right right around 2500 in last month a
few other members to thank on my website
oh wow there are just massive dumps of
memberships happening Mark Clark just
signed up at joinpakman.com Devin Brody
Thomas Murphy
Rhiannon Cahill
Charles Trimble and Pedro Hernandez now
I don't know if that's Pedro from
Colombia but it might be West in Switzer
and Casey Weaver have signed up that's
eight Diane Hemphill and Steve Bowker
puts us at 10 Diane bishop and Julie
Finney is 12.
and then of course uh turtle mitchison
and dog Dylan are 14 putting us at 46.
uh very very much right on the nose
okay
let's see so we are standing by for two
two things we are expecting to hear from
Donald Trump at the U.S border
momentarily I anticipate he will lie
that the border wall is done and I
anticipate he will lie that Mexico paid
for it we also then are standing by for
a briefing from the FBI and acting U.S
attorney Michael Sherwin on the riotous
violent Insurrection that took place on
January 6th so we're standing by for two
different things right now my guess is
even though they're both scheduled for
the same time that Trump will be very
late and we will hear from the FBI first
that's that's my guess at this point in
time
Rick Hunter says who's the greatest
Argentinian soccer player is it messy
uh you know he this is the tough thing
about talking about that this is sort of
like when people say is Michael Jordan
better than LeBron James first of all
there is no way there's a generational
thing where people who saw Jordan in his
prime like me probably all else being
equal would would lean towards Jordan
there's another uh issue which is that
the physicality of the game has changed
and what we know now about building the
ideal physique for different sports has
changed dramatically uh and so there's a
real chance that LeBron in his prime
maybe could beat Jordan in his prime but
the point is that the NBA has become
different physically players tend to
carry more muscle and you know so on and
so on so the point is I think it's very
difficult when you're talking about
players of different generations to
really make these comparisons okay
uh and and much the same way you know
the way soccer players train at this
point is different so I I don't know I
think it's not clear but I would
certainly say I would certainly say that
uh Messi and Maradona are both uh uh in
in at the absolute top at their
respective times the number one players
for sure okay thank you very much I
appreciate it let's not be uh
let's let's not get crazy okay we are
now going to see
[Music]
oh my God are you kidding me
okay so Trump's at the border wall I
guess they're pointing out different
elements of the wall to him uh yep
that's the wall sir they told me sir
Mexico is on the other side and I said
we've got to have a country if we don't
have a border we don't have a country
and then they said sir is that your real
hair and I said of course it is
okay so standing by here for Donald
Trump very very important uh Mr Chris
says can't disqualify Trump from holding
future office unless he's convicted
first by a two-thirds majority the 2D
disqualification vote is by simple
majority 2D qualification vote okay
I think I should better inform myself
about some of these details
I think that that would be useful
Bean products says watching on the
YouTube feed wanted to give you my free
substance Destiny is no longer partnered
I'm not partnered either I'm a twitch
affiliate
uh just to Twitch a lowly lowly twitch
affiliate
and that's uh that's the reality all
right so we're going to hear from Trump
soon what are the odds of marijuana
legalization I'm guessing you mean under
Joe Biden very very low Joe Biden hasn't
even talked about legalization he's
talked about D Crim also known as
decriminalization so let's try to hold
Joe Biden accountable to the things he
promised rather than the things he
didn't but I do think that if we see
significant if we see uh
decriminalization happen at the national
level
we will see many more states legalize
recreationally there's no doubt at all
no no doubt at all
uh people asking me for the what is the
best Argentinian Cuisine dish there
would be we don't have 10 hours guys so
unfortunately I won't I won't be able to
deal with that but and you know the
other issue is that a lot of Argentinian
dishes have Origins elsewhere like for
example milanesa is one of my favorite
Argentinian dishes but the term Milan is
literally in the name
so is that really Argentinian Trump now
seems to be signing the wall
yep he's signing can you imagine
anything more sycophantic and and
ridiculous Trump is signing the wall
with a sharpie
this is the stupidest timeline I've ever
been involved in
unbelievable yeah you could also make
the argument that milanesa is really a
is German Wienerschnitzel
I I it's you know I don't disagree with
that certainly empanadas are very much
at the top of the list
um there's just so many great
Argentinian Foods
I was at the Trump rally when he landed
our area is 90 Hispanic but the rally
was majority Anglo
not surprised not surprised
Trump uh pumping his fists and do we
even know for sure that Trump will make
remarks it says here delivers remarks
but you never know when these things uh
get changed or rescheduled Trump may
have may have changed his mind
oh now me people are saying wiener
schnitzel is not even German it's
actually Austrian
this is exactly my point this is exactly
my point who knows who knows hey boss
legal student here previous commenter is
correct cannot be barred from office
without a two-thirds conviction love the
show my mom doesn't like politics but
loves you thank you thank you to
chalkway pitchford's Mom very much
appreciate that
hello and welcome all right Trump is on
the move is he approaching a mic a very
very gingerly going down those steps as
we've seen him do before there's quite a
commotion we see the prompters here and
the and the presidential seal in the
foreground so we may be very close very
very close to uh hearing from Trump
what's one of the best dishes I've had
in Argentina when I was in Mendoza
Argentina I went to Francis malman's
restaurant 1884 and I had a beef
milanesa it was one of the best I ever
had one of the absolute best
uh
highly recommend it
highly recommended okay
certainly no mask from Trump although
many of the people around him are masked
at this point in time
again I'm anticipating a lie about the
completion of the border wall and a lie
about who paid for it
a big big thank you to the additional 21
people who just signed up via twitch
that puts us at 67.
really appreciate it guys and as we wait
for Trump here I'll just thank a few
more website subscribers Corey champion
uh Nico matinen Terrell shorter Laura
Moss has signed up Cindy Pearsall and
Robert Velez
also big thank you to Sean Troxel and
Sergio Aragon
Linda joy and Jefferson Henderson thank
you very much that's 10 John widget
and Sadie Flames puts us at 12 and then
Luke shance and Nikki love Salinas is 14
putting us at 81 a small crowd for
Donald Trump as you can see
this is at the border and I'm expect
expecting very very weaponized
propaganda and as we saw last week uh
when we say weaponized disinformation
we saw it weaponized last week it's not
a joke
it's not a joke
means Vienna so weiner is of Vienna oh
so wiener schnitzel is a Vienna
schnitzel very important
do you think the current political
climate is poisoned the Trump brand
enough that it will make challenging for
a trump 2024 ticket I do think so I do
think so
yeah
uh apparently masks not even required in
the crowd how do you do an event in the
middle of a global Hundred Year pandemic
and you don't even mandate that
everybody in the crowd wear a mask
how I just I just don't get it let's
listen to the uh sounds
okay it's pretty bad yeah so we'll keep
it muted you never condemned condemned
the antifa riots in Pac-Man in Portland
Pac-Man hypocrite much no so very much
unlike a whole bunch of the Hypocrites
that are out and around
my position has been exactly the same on
violence during political demonstrations
I uh condemned it when we saw it in a
variety of cities around the country my
position has been identical the
differences we saw way more of it on
January 6th and it was incited by the
president of the United States that's a
key difference
the president of the United States
states incited that riotous mob so I
hope that was worth
you know five dollars David do you like
mate my Spanish teacher in high school
lived in Argentina and would drink it
every day in class no I've never gotten
into mate not my thing
they can't even pretend to fill the
seats
why hasn't the Biden Harris ticket thank
the beautiful bathers for their win
yes
people who bathe
seem to have voted for Biden I guess is
the the point
um love matambre made with love Vive
Argentina yeah my diamond is a great
dish it really is
am I concerned about lack of content
once Trump is gone not at all not at all
I've gotten a few messages about this so
I've actually I've gotten messages from
people just genuinely concerned and
messages from people looking to troll me
and tell me that I'm circling the drain
saying as soon as Trump's gone my show
ends and uh you know every time when
Bush left and Obama won I got emails
saying it's over for you Pacman it's
over you were in the opposition now
you're not the show is over the show
quadrupled in size during the Obama
Administration or 6X then Trump won and
I got messages from people saying David
now that you Hillary lost so now you're
done
and I think the show tripled in size
again
uh and listen you know a lot of the
topics that do best are not Trump topics
when we look at the insanity
disinformation on right-wing media those
those clips do as well as Trump related
Clips
um so no I'm not worried the show will
evolve by the way I don't think Trump is
going away on January 20th uh but no I
know there's a lot of people waiting for
the show to just have nothing to talk
about I predict that uh we will have
plenty plenty to talk about I appreciate
the concern though from people who are
just genuinely concerned FBI predicting
violence in all 50 states yes we covered
that on today's podcast
you can get the podcast anywhere that
podcasts exist
what happens to the Lincoln project
after January 20th I think they go back
to just being regular Republicans
that's my instinct although many of them
claimed they're never going back to the
party I think on ideology they go back
is Trump in this tent right now is this
a sort of green room that they've
erected for Trump is that what am I
understanding what's going on because
you just I looked away for a second and
he seemed to disappear
that is what's going on okay
and hold on I'm being sent messages
about other things that I should be
covering
let me see what the deal is with that
uh okay
what on Earth is going on yeah no we're
covering this right now yeah I'm getting
messages from people saying cover the
uh
uh cover the FBI thing but Trump's about
to start and the FBI thing still hasn't
even started actually
okay here is Donald Trump
an American
oh God this again
[Music]
all right so uh once again this is Trump
at the border expecting him to lie about
the completion of the wall and expecting
him to lie that Mexico paid for it those
are my only predictions here
[Music]
thank you very much thank you everybody
great honor to be here we worked long
and hard please sit down we've worked
long and hard to get this done they said
it couldn't be done well it wasn't so
done one of the largest infrastructure I
already called the history of our
country I'm honored to be here in the
Rio Grande Valley with the courageous
men and women of Customs and Border
Patrol these people are uh incredible
they're really incredible I've gotten to
know you very well over the last four
years many of you are friends from all
of the work we did in designing the wall
we got it exactly as you wanted it
everything and you just didn't build it
detective played on top I say why did we
put that and they said we needed for
Extra Protection climb plate and we have
everything you want that's steel it's
concrete inside the steel and then it's
rebar a lot of heavy rebar inside heavy
and it's as strong as you're going to
get and strong as you can have but we
gave you 100 of what you wanted so now
you have no excuses I didn't want you to
have any excuses
and you set records and we can't let
that next Administration even think
about taking it down if you can believe
that I don't think that will happen I
think when you see what it does and how
it's so important for our country
nobody's going to be touching it and
Country you are very proud of it and
you're proud of the work you did because
we really designed it together yeah
we're joined together to celebrate a
great achievement the extraordinarily
successful building of the wall they
didn't build it on the southern border
before we begin I'd like to say that
free speech is under assault here we go
the 25th amendment is of zero risk to me
but we'll come back to haunt Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration
as the expression goes be careful it
would be Trump's cabinet it would be
Trump's cabinet doing it this is a
continuation of the greatest and most
vicious Witch Hunt in the history of our
country that is causing tremendous anger
and Division and pain oh my God a lot
greater than most people will ever
understand this is wild she's very
dangerous for the USA especially at this
very tender time
and now I'd like to briefly address the
events of last week oh here we go
millions of our citizens watched on
Wednesday as a mob storm the capital and
trash the halls of government walls as I
have consistently said throughout my
Administration we believe in respecting
America's history and traditions not
tearing them Confederate history we
believe in the rule of law not in
violence or rioting
because of the pandemic horrible
horrible invisible enemy and despite our
tremendous success
developing a vaccine years before he had
nothing to do with it evenly remotely
possible nobody thought it was going to
be possible they said it would take five
years sir it will take seven years all
of our scientists were saying sir our
advisors we knew exactly when it would
be done years would be December's Maybe
well we did it just like I said we would
and we had it out
years and years before they thought it
was possible a decade before now
delivering it to States including your
state where your governor and government
are doing a terrific job in getting it
administered in Texas
and Florida is doing great some of them
are doing great some aren't doing as
well but they have all they can handle
and we get it to them as fast as they
need it and even faster faster than they
need it there you go They're calling it
a medical miracle and this has been a
difficult year and a very difficult
election
the pandemic has made it a very very
difficult year for our country and
virtually every country all over the
world
now is the time for our nation to heal
and it's time for peace and for calm
well maybe don't incite a ride expect
for law enforcement and the great people
within law enforcement so many are here
is the foundation of the Maga agenda
and We're a nation of Law and We're a
nation of order
that is why we're here today to talk
about what we must do to uphold the rule
of law in America so he said he was
going to talk about what happened he
didn't really talk about what happened
law enforcement Heroes which is exactly
what you are do you feel like a hero
yeah I think you do right
you do and you are
I want to thank Customs and Border
Patrol commissioner Mark Morgan
who's been incredible where's Mark Mark
stand up Mark
great job did he say costumes
Chief Patrol agent Brian Hastings Brian
thank you very much great job
he's so happy with he said sir this
really works
and most importantly the brave law
enforcement officers who risk their
lives every day to protect our families
and our country
I also want to thank a tremendous
gentleman a friend of mine Tom Holman
he's a great American Patriot and he was
with us right from the beginning right
Tom you knew exactly he said we need a
wall
when they were saying no no we need
drones we need drones I said why so you
could watch the people pour into our
country illegally
and I want to thank you very much John
what a what a professional job you've
done all of you people incredible
everyone here today is part of an
incredible success story this is a real
success story
when I took office we inherited a broken
dysfunctional and open border
everybody was pouring in at will
working alongside the heroes in this
Great Outdoor space looking at our wall
we reformed our immigration system and
achieved the most secure Southern Border
in U.S history
it is at a level that it's never been
before
just eight more days guys cartels the
just eight more days and the special
interests and we restored the rule of
law
for years special interest lobbyists are
just flying through the Border cure the
Border only to get elected
and to do the absolute exact opposite
they even promised a wall if you
remember
about 10 years ago they promised a wall
but they couldn't get it built it wasn't
easy getting it built getting it
financed was tough getting it built was
even tougher
all the different chains of title and
all the different things we had to go
through very very complex and very
difficult but we got it done but they
had it
years ago you remember that better than
anybody right and they never got it done
they never ever
completed the task
and then ultimately the money was sent
back to the federal government
uh spent but no wall was built
but unlike those who came before me I
kept imagine having the gall to have
incited a riotous uh Insurrection and
then show up and not address the fact
that it was exclusively your supporters
who did it on your say-so and and talk
about this wall That's not I mean you
can see that the wall it's it's
obviously not even fully built it ends
you can see it over his left shoulder it
ends right there and I'm looking at the
wall and I'm walking and walking
and I'm used to like a development
project where you could walk a wall you
know 10 acres five acres two acres one
acre
and I realized
that's a long time that's a big walk
a lot of it a lot of the world you have
is incredibly natural it's you have the
mountains you have the rivers you have
some very powerful water areas
virtually impossible to get by so really
powerful water areas really really
powerful
because it's been so successful that
we've added nearly 300 miles and that's
currently under construction this was
our original wish to get these areas
water areas with the power of God truly
and now we have it it's either in
construction or pre-construction an
additional 300 miles pre-construction in
every region that we've built the wall
illegal Crossings and drug smuggling
have plummeted absolutely plummeted but
where have they gone the Rio Grande
Valley Crossings have dropped nearly 80
percent in Yuma Arizona illegal entries
have been slashed by 90 percent
Nationwide ice and border patrol have
seized over 2 million pounds of fentanyl
heroin meth and other deadly narcotics
saving thousands and thousands of lives
we've arrested nearly 500 000 illegal
aliens with criminal records some with
very serious criminal records
of the type you don't want to know about
like murder
we removed nearly twenty thousand gang
members from the United States including
four thousand five hundred members of
MS-13 probably
the worst gang of them all through the
landmark reforms we've put into place we
have ended the immigration chaos and
re-established American sovereignty our
most important reform was ending Catch
and Release not easy to do
dealing with Congress it's very very
difficult which is the functional
equivalent of open borders but even
worse it's catch and release them it
means release into our country not into
another country this policy was
exploited by vicious criminal
organizations who understood the laws
better than our people understood them
for years
to spread misery and suffering and drugs
all across the hemisphere now instead of
Catch and Release we have detain and
remove it's called detain and remove
doesn't that sound better
Trump caught somebody with a marijuana
recently and was Furious under the old
broken system if you merely requested
Asylum you were released into the
country
the most ridiculous thing anyone's ever
seen
and we were taking in some people that
you didn't want to have in your country
we instituted a series of historic
policy changes to shut down
Asylum fraud and that's what we did this
includes the groundbreaking agreement
with Mexico known as the migrant
protection protocol will he say Mexico
paid for the wall
under this agreement if an illegal alien
requests Asylum they have to wait in
Mexico until their case is heard they
used to wait here and when they were
waiting they would say bye-bye and
they'd disappear somewhere into our
country and essentially would never find
them again would never see him again
this one measure alone ended a
humanitarian crisis and saved countless
lives and especially I have to say lives
from crime
I want to thank the great president of
Mexico
he is a great gentleman a friend say his
name
president obrador there you go he is a
man who really knows what's happening
and he loves his country and he also
loves the United States but I want to
thank for his friendship and his
professional work in relationship
we actually had 27 000 Mexican soldiers
guarding our borders over the last two
years nobody thought that was possible
and they made it very very difficult and
that's why the numbers were able to
plunge even during the construction of
the wall
and by the way one of the big elements
of the wall that make it so successful
is we can have far fewer people working
now they can be working on other things
other things related to crime and
drug prevention and a lot of other
elements they're working on because we
save massive numbers of people drug
prevention included here we have the
most sophisticated camera systems and
most sophisticated electronic systems
anywhere in the world highly Advanced
electricity agreements with the northern
triangle that's
Guatemala Honduras and El Salvador under
these critical Asylum cooperation
agreements the burden of illegal
immigration is now shared all across the
region
now when an illegal immigrant is
arrested at our border they can be sent
to a neighboring country instead of into
a U.S Community
prior to my getting here countries
wouldn't accept them they would say no
no no I said well you've got to take
them first month I'll never forget these
gentlemen right here came to me they
said they won't take them back sir they
came they may be murderers they may be
cartel
heads they may be some really vicious
people the countries didn't want them
back
and I stopped all payments to those
countries I stopped everything going to
those countries
and after it was stopped for about a
month you remember
after it was stopped for about a month
they called they said we'd love to have
them back
and I never gave him as much money as
they were getting by the way but they
got what what is he talking about and
they'd say don't ever even think about
Landing that plane
and they take them by boat and they take
them by bus and they wouldn't let them
into their countries and all of a sudden
they say welcome back we love having you
so it was a great thing and now they do
take them back and the relationship with
those countries I don't know what he's
talking about relationship is a much
better one than it was before
in addition to our agreements with
Mexico Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador
we have systematically reformed the
regulatory code
to return Asylum to its original legal
meaning and purpose not a free ticket
for entry
a recent comprehensive report by the
Department of Homeland Security and
Justice show how effective our reforms
have been really passionate delivering
ministers their removal would be it
would be a disaster for our country I
know they're thinking about removing
them I hope they don't do that
I hope they don't do that it'll be a
absolute travesty for our country the
report conclusively proves once and for
all that aliens released at the border
remain at large in the country
and do not return home they won't go
home
and you've rarely find them it's very
tough to find them so we have
aliens released in our country many of
whom are serious criminals
and we've stopped that I I know I'm not
I'm trying I'm resisting but I see
people in the chat AL Salvador like
Albert and Guatemala oh my God it I I
it's but I'm trying to I'm trying to
behave I see people are picking up on it
you are apprehended and immediately
safely removed from our country
without this core principle there is no
border there is no law
there is no water there's no country my
Administration also instituted vital
Public Health measures On the Border in
response to the China virus under title
42 of the U.S code illegal immigrants
are being promptly removed to protect
the health of Border agents
other migrants and local communities and
the public at large removing these
protections would invite a public health
catastrophe of epic
proportions as you probably know in
Tijuana various parts of Mexico Tijuana
like Aunt Juana
it's Tijuana I I that one really gets me
Tia Tia where are you getting that I
call it the China plague a lot of
different names
but we always call it I actually had a
Tijuana she died a couple years ago I
loved her it was my great aunt
uh and she would make a mean gefil to
fish it was my Tiajuana that we're in
great shape but on the other side of
Mexico they're suffering greatly with
the virus
it's been incredible what we've achieved
and we didn't do the wall because of
covid we did the wall because of right
no we don't think you think that that
the virus can't pass the wall we don't
think you're that stupid although you
know Along Came this horrible plague We
inherited Dangerously
Lawless border the people that work here
are unbelievably Brave I've seen what
they have to endure what they have to go
through
they're tough they're strong
and they're great Patriots great
Americans we fixed it and we secured it
we empowered our wonderful ice and
border patrol to fulfill their roasts
and sworn officers
they became sworn officers of the law
and they love their job it's a tough job
it's a nasty job
nasty they're not paid what they should
be paid to be honest but we got
interesting we got a job interesting
these are incredibly talented people
that could probably do a lot better in
terms of
economics than they do here but they
love what they do and they love their
country
we also put into place vital measures to
protect American workers keep out
terrorists and stop the abuse of our
welfare system where would they'd come
up go in our welfare system and live for
years the almost non-existent to be fair
without ever having a job
we also have and we had but we have them
all the time we have terrorists from the
Middle East coming into our country
through the southern border that was
before what you see right here
because it was easier to come into our
country through the southern border than
it was through airports or any other
means so they'd kill a question about
that and then work their way up and
they'd come into our country
and these are not people by the way a
lot of people getting banned in the chat
mostly twitch it's interesting from some
very seriously dangerous places in the
Middle East
and the numbers are far greater than
anybody would understand really far
greater removing any of these measures
would hamstring our workers endanger our
country and cost taxpayers hundreds of
billions of dollars a year
no matter our party we should all agree
on the need to protect our workers our
families and our citizens
of all backgrounds no matter who they
are in particular of our
border security measures are reversed it
will trigger a tidal wave of illegal
immigration a wave like you've never
seen before and I can tell you that
already
waves are starting to come up from two
thousand and a thousand and 500 miles
away we see what's coming the Caravans
are back coming because they think that
it's just in time at the end it's going
to be a gravy train change the name from
the Caravans which I think we came up
with sure the gravy train because that's
what they're looking for looking for the
gravy
this will be an unmitigated Calamity for
National Security Public Safety and
Public Health
it would destroy millions and millions
of jobs and claim thousands of innocent
lives
the policies I put into place are
uniformly and strongly supported by the
men and women of ice and border and just
to be clear there's people saying you
shouldn't ban people for different
opinions believe me we're not the the
the standard at which you get banned on
these channels is pretty damn it's too
high I would even argue in front of me
to terminate those policies
is knowingly to put America in really
serious danger and to override
the great career experts that have
worked so hard those from DHS
at this very moment Smugglers and
coyotes are preparing to Surge the
Border if our policies are loosened or
removed I mean they're literally waiting
right on the other side big groups of
people some of them very unsavory I
might add
this is an entirely preventable tragedy
it's waiting to happen the safety of our
nation must come before politics we have
many disagreements in the country but we
should all agree the urgent need to
secure our borders protect our homeland
and allow law enforcement to fulfill its
mission
without political interference Eisen
border patrol agents wore a sacred oath
to uphold the law and no
political appointee should ever order
them to violate that oath these are real
experts they really get it
and I'll tell you who else gets it the
Hispanic population of our country gets
uh-oh this is dicey it's not only did I
win Texas in historic numbers
but I won border towns which are largely
Hispanic and people were that's pretty
narrow I mean and he lost the Hispanic
vote and most of the Border areas are
red anyway so it's a very stupid thing
to say
that nobody's had since reconstruction
reconstruction I mean dude you lost
Georgia
and uh largely Hispanic they understand
it better than anybody and they want law
enforcement to help them help them Live
Safe lives the laws that congress passed
must be upheld to the men and women of
ice Customs and Border Protection and
all across DHS
law enforcement in general you have
earned the Everlasting gratitude of our
nation you have no idea how much
our nation loves you and respects you I
don't think you do have an idea but it's
true okay I only hope and pray that your
voice will be heard honored heated and
respected long into the future all right
let's cut to the FBI does this cross a
threshold domestic terrorism because
they are political targets this is more
important this was designed to either
pull First Responders away from the
scene as the capital was breached or an
effort to maim lawmakers as they
evacuated
so I'll try to address that question for
the best I can so yes those two pipe
bombs that were found were found both
outside the RNC and the DNC offices near
the capitol grounds and uh look to begin
they were real devices they were they
had explosive uh igniters they had
timers uh we don't know obviously
exactly why they did not go off that's
being investigated they were destroyed
disabled by Capitol Police with the
assistance of the ATF and that is all
obviously being vetted and investigated
what was the purpose of those devices
being planted was it a diversionary type
of a tactic used by some of these Riders
was it something or did it have some
other type of Nefarious purpose so that
is what the ATF the FBI MPD are looking
at as we speak right now and looking for
those persons that planted those devices
in terms of the conduct related to
planning those you know pipe bombs the
the you know the mention of domestic
terrorism mentioned this before I don't
like this tyranny of labels saying and
act as domestic terrorism we have plenty
of federal resources at our disposal
plenty of federal charges to address all
of this conduct from felony murder
related to The Possession and use of
destructive devices to seditious
conspiracy you know under the federal
law that has significant penalties and
as mentioned with this strike force that
was established to focus strictly on
sedition charges we're looking at and
treating this just like a significant
International counterterrorism or
counterintelligence operation we're
looking at everything Money travel
records uh looking at disposition
movement communication records so no
resource related to the FBI or the U.S
attorney's office will will be unchecked
in terms of trying to determine exactly
if there was a command and control how
it operated and how they executed these
uh these activities huh
the next question
is from Peter Thomas from ABC News
please go ahead
yes thank you
um are you looking at the possibility
that some of these suspects were
attempting or planning to take members
of Congress hostage important
um so I want to talk about Mike's uh the
prior question first just because I want
to emphasize
um that we have a 50 000 reward out for
the information any information uh and
identification of the individual or
individuals that left the pipe bomb so
beautiful I just want to make that
perfectly clear and that we're looking
at all angles in that uh every tool
every rock is being unturned because we
have to bring that person to Justice or
people to Justice
um
so the the the the the can you repeat
the question please
hostages okay are you looking at the
possibility that some of these suspects
who reached the capitol who had this
ties and other things were looking at
the possibility of taking members of
Congress or others hostages so like I
answered the the last couple questions
before we are looking at all angles here
we're we're looking we're interviewing
everyone interviewing Witnesses and
interviewing subjects as they get
arrested around the country and we love
that District as well uh to ascertain
the true purpose
um of some of these individuals in the
capital that day
the next question is from Jake Gibson
from Fox News please this is great this
is better than the Trump thing thank you
first of all I have two actually number
one uh Senator Cassidy has tweeted out a
photo that he said was of an individual
that uh authorities wanted to uh to get
in contact with in connection possibly
with the killing of uh Capital police
officer sick Nick number one can you
give us any type of update on that uh
situation number two I know you talked
about intelligence leading up to the day
before or leading up to the day of the
riots but there are some specific
reports out that there was a you know at
least one report out of FBI in Norfolk
that painted a pretty Grim picture
um can you confirm that and and were
were Authorities on the hill uh you know
really ready for what was coming at them
so the the the investigation to officer
sickness
um
passing is is an ongoing investigation
we are looking at everything that we
possibly can it is it cuts us to a core
that one of our law enforcement Brethren
uh passed away
um so we're it's an ongoing
investigation there's a lot of tools and
interviews that we're still conducting
is is a whole host of video that's out
there uh we're reviewing all that
information as for the information that
that's being uh presented out there uh
right now about Norfolk
um that was a
thread on a message board that was not
attributed was being attributable to an
individual person we like I said my
statement we deal in specifics and facts
um that information when my office in uh
washer field office received that
information
we briefed that within 40 minutes to our
law enforcement Partners the federal
state and law enforcement partners that
we have on command post it got ingested
into the jttf system and was again
shared with all our law enforcement
Partners through that process that we
have and that's that's the action that
we took on that
um and that's it
yep this concludes our question and
answer session as well as the conference
thank you for attending today's
presentation you may now disconnect all
right so that's that and it looks like
Trump is also done let's go and maybe we
could just check out just the last few
moments of the Trump event
uh let's see
where Trump was on this
this is weird
did that did that never even start
that's strange
huh this is all really odd
so that event ended
and did they already upload it
all right well it's gone so we're not
gonna We're not gonna be hearing from
Trump interesting
uh okay so very very important stuff uh
we are going to be following I've got a
lot of homework to do for tomorrow's
show let me put it that way and I see
that oh I only missed two minutes good I
see a lot of people asking me my
thoughts on the FBI memo about 50 riots
um in the next week
talked about that on today's podcast you
can get it now it just came out eight
minutes ago so you can get that
um asked about a bunch of the things
people are asking about we talked about
today on the broadcast show okay so
short stream today have a lot of work to
catch up on appreciate everybody who
signed up we have gotten over the 2000
twitch sub Milestone once again I really
do appreciate that on the way out hit
the Subscribe button on YouTube hit the
follow button on Twitch we do want to
get to a hundred thousand twitch
followers we're almost at 75k already
and I'll be talking to everybody again
very very soon